I speaking of killing people I heard
that the FDA is investigating is maybe
going to investigate Logan Paul's Prime
energy drink and uh KSI I just followed
him on Instagram
I I remember uh KSI when KSI and Logan
Paul were gonna um box and they boxed
but beforehand KSI was like dude we have
to do like this press conference can you
please come out and be the surprise
guest and I was like oh yeah let me
think about it and I never got back to
him because I was like what the [__] am
I going to say you want me to roast them
I don't like roasting people
also I should have never [__]
remember I remember when I did that
thing about uh Logan Paul I was making a
[__] years ago I make a photo of him
I shouldn't have done that dude he was
going through enough pain to be clear I
love Logan Paul I didn't know this but
it has five times
caffeine as Coca-Cola right it's not
right is that what it is
six cans of coke dude and all I say is
this to that dude honestly like being if
I'm being totally real
honestly
hell yes
me after five sips of prime hell yes
yep a hundred percent dude give me that
[__] I'll go on stage my [__] head
will pop off it'd be like that old Jim
Carrey skit when he's playing Michael
Bolton and he goes win a man and his
[__] head just explodes
from a Living Color dude awesome I want
all that caffeine
so
so I love it props to them for making a
drink finally with enough caffeine
finally an influencer backed energy
drink that has earned viral popularity
among children is facing scrutiny for
lawmakers although if you are [__] 12
drinking two primes you know oh that's
like 10 that's like 12 Cokes
yikes I'm sure it's got sugar in it too
um Senator Charles Schumer called on the
Food and Drug Administration is that is
he related to uh Amy Schumer I heard he
was
although that sounds like something that
somebody would say
uh see if they're related
um a beverage brand found by YouTube
Stars Logan Paul and KSI that has become
something of an obsession among
influence yeah it [__] apparently in
the UK it's Bonkers you can't even get
it on Sunday Charles Schumer called in
the drug food the [__] snitch ass
[__] you know it was an
immediate sensation this is the thing
dude the government doesn't want you
making a lot of [__] money dude they
want to control you this is crazy dude
God damn it I sound like a [__]
Biden's a lizard I sound like I'm
queuing on dude
what am I doing I need to stop
oh [__]
am I queuing on it probably does have
the same amount of caffeine as [__]
Monster Energy and [__] like that I
don't know I don't know [__]
but um it's like such [__] dude
you know what they're trying to do
they're trying to [__] honestly keep
a black man down and that's terrible and
I mean KSI not Logan Paul right
that's it
it's it's a race thing finally good it's
a race thing Schumer's racist crazy
[Music]
crazy crazy